Sometimes timing isn't always on our side
We might meet people during significant transitions. We are about to make.
Whether it means traveling overseas or having to stay in one place longer than we expected, life doesn't stop for anyone
All we can really do is take care of ourselves and get ready for the journey. We are about to begin
Here are five signs you might not be ready for a long-distance relationship
One you rely on physical intimacy alone to feel close to your partner
Does the idea of being far away from your partner scare you? Of course it does and it's okay to admit this.
In fact it's better to ask yourself this question before deciding whether to go through the motions of holding on to a long-distance relationship
If you need to see your partner every day and rely on physical touch to feel close to them
Going long-distance may actually do you more harm than good
The idea of letting go might be scary but the emotional turbulence from being far away from your partner
Could be a lot more hurtful in the end
Two you're already facing communication problems with your lover
Communication is an important aspect that often makes or breaks relationships
But in long-distance relationships its relied on even more when two people can't communicate in person
If you're already facing problems in person going long-distance might make matters worse when misunderstandings are common and you rely on technology to communicate
Three you haven't had the difficult conversations yet
As lovers learn more about each other over time, their differences can sometimes tear them apart
Even if you're not ready to have some of the more serious conversations like marriage and children
You should be clear with each other while you are looking for in a relationship before you take it long distance
Four you get jealous easily
It's normal to have insecurities. Everyone does
But if you get jealous easily or often get paranoid that your partner will cheat on you with someone else
Those issues have to be sorted out before the two of you go long-distance
It's unrealistic to believe that your partner will not speak to or hang out with other people
While you are apart and you will need to trust that they are staying loyal
Relationships are built on the foundation of trust and there will only be less when you can't check in in person
Five you're already having second thoughts about who you're with
Have you ever dated someone only to find out later that the two of you just aren't as compatible as you thought
Breakups are hard but it's even harder to stay with someone
You know isn't right for you
If you're already hesitating and having a hard time imagining a future together
Perhaps it's time to sit down with your partner and let them know what's on your mind
It's okay to be scared, but don't let it hold you back from making an important decision
You are your first priority and you must surround yourself with whatever feels right for you
How else might you know that you're not ready for a long-distance relationship?
Let us know down below
Also, be sure to subscribe to our channel as well for more helpful tips and share this video with others
With your help we can reach more people and explore relationship problems and mental health issues together
Thanks for watching